for me going to college was just an
assumption that was made and there was
no challenging whether you know it you
just you go to copy for smart you do
well in school you go to college because
that's how you're successful in life and
I think that's true for a lot of people
and I really liked college the decision
to drop out was not one that I took
lightly and I don't think it's necessary
like I didn't drop out and then figure
out what I wanted to do with my life
I had a job offer to be a research
assistant to work at a talent agency in
Hollywood I had this I had these offers
and I I did the math and I said hey if
these were my offers when I was when I
was on the day after graduation I have
considered colleges success so that's
that's why I personally dropped out and
a few years ago I wrote an article about
dropping out of college and sort of what
that experience was like and how it
shaped my life and the the funny or
scary thing is that it now ranks really
well on Google if you if you search the
phrase dropping out of college and so I
get a lot of emails almost every day at
like 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning some
kid who's not happy with college comes
back to his dorm room and google that
phrase and then they email me and a lot
of times they want me to tell them that
it's okay to drop out of college and I
usually don't one because it was such an
it was such a terrifying decision to
make it was and it it was so unpleasant
I mean my parents didn't take it well
and I it was so hard that I don't I
don't
I'm not glib about recommending it to
other people but also I think Mark
Zuckerberg again didn't drop out of
college to create Facebook he created
Facebook in college and then he moved to
California for the summer and it was
doing so well it he decided not to go
back I think Bill Gates's story is
similar most of the really successful
college dropouts used the platform that
is going to a university it's using the
status of being a student they they
started something and then it it it just
it got going quickly enough that it
didn't make sense to continue going to
school so I think college is a great
default it's not a great default if
you're going to be $200,000 in debt
the end of it but it's a great default
to sort of figure out what you're doing
it's a safe place to experiment and
learn things I don't know what I would
tell my own kids it seems crazy to me
that 18 year I need to do 18 plus years
of savings to pay for this for them
but but I do think that quitting college
and dropping out of college to do
something different are inherently
different things right if I get an email
from someone and they say I'm failing
all my classes I want to drop out just
like you did I say you know you need to
figure out why you were not successful
in school and solved that problem before
you before you strike out on your own
where you have even less of a safety net
I do think though and it's people have
made this argument about Peter Thiel's
Foundation which which creates
fellowships that encourages kids to drop
out of college I do think questioning
whether college is the right choice for
you is worth doing and and I do think
the stigma about dropping out is is is
is is worth reducing as well you know
when you when you drop out of college
and your parents go you're throwing your
life away how can you do this you know
you can't say it worked out for Bill
Gates because the response is you're not
Bill Gates right and and and and really
you can be successful without a college
degree and it's not as hard as people
think and we shouldn't make it we
shouldn't make it incredibly hard for a
20 year old to bet on themselves and to
make them feel like they're throwing
their life away for for trying something
different